>>> HALF OF KYIV IS IN THE DARK
THIS MORNING AFTER RUSSIAN
STRIKES KNOCKED POWER OUT OF
MUCH OF THE COUNTRY.
BAD WEATHER NOW SLOWING DOWN
REPAIR CREWS RACING TO RESTORE
THAT POWER AS UKRAINIANS ARE
TOLD TO PREPARE FOR MORE
BLACKOUTS.
THAT MEANS THERE COULD BE MORE
REMARKABLE SCENES LIKE THIS ONE.
DOCTORS IN KYIV PERFORMING HEART
SURGERY BASICALLY BY FLASHLIGHT
BECAUSE THEIR HOSPITAL HAD NO
LIGHTS.
THESE IMAGES COMING OUT OF WHAT
LIFE IS LIKE FOR THESE
UKRAINIANS NOW AS THEY ARE
DEALING WITH WHAT RUSSIA IS
DOING, WHICH IS BASICALLY THIS
TERROR CAMPAIGN AS YOU HEARD THE
NATO SECRETARY GENERAL DESCRIBE
IT AS.
THEY'RE JUST REMARKABLE.
>> YEAH.
EXTRAORDINARY SCENES.
THIS CAME FROM THE HEAD OF
MEDICAL SERVICES AT THE KYIV
HEART INSTITUTION.
THIS WAS A CHILD UNDERGOING
EMERGENCY OPEN HEART SURGERY.
THE OPERATION WAS UNDER WAY WHEN
THE LIGHTS WENT OUT.
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE IMAGES THE
DOCTORS KEPT GOING, USED HEAD
LAMPS AND CONTINUED WITH THE
SURGERY.
THEY WORKED THROUGH THE NIGHT
ACCORDING TO THE HEAD OF MEDICAL
SERVICES AND THEY DID NOT LOSE A
SINGLE PATIENT.
MORE EXTRAORDINARY IS THE FACT
THIS WAS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
WE CAN SHOW YOU ANOTHER IMAGE
FROM ANOTHER HOSPITAL IN DNIPRO
IN CENTRAL SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
THERE THERE WAS AN OPERATION ON
A 23-YEAR-OLD MAN, SIMILAR
SCENARIO, THE LIGHTS WENT OUT,
BUT HE SAID THAT PATIENT MADE
IT.
IT SHOWS THAT RUSSIA'S ATTACKS
ON THE POWER SYSTEM IS CREATING
THESE LIFE AND DEATH SCENARIOS.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
REPORTING ON THE EFFORTS TO
RESTORE POWER IN THE REGION,
WHAT'S THE LATEST?
>> Reporter: WE HEARD FROM THE
ELECTRICITY TRANCE MTRANSMITTER
IN THE COUNTRY, THEY SAY THEY'VE
RESTORED 70% OF DEMAND, UP FROM
50% YESTERDAY EVENING SO THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING THROUGH THE NIGHT.
THE NUCLEAR PLANTS WHICH FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN DECADES WERE TAKEN
OFF LINE OFF THE GRID BUT THE
ATTACKS ARE BACK ONLINE.
RAMPING UP THEIR OWN ELECTRICITY
GENERATION.
BUT THEY'RE BEING HAMPERED BY
BAD WEATHER.
I WANT TODAY POINT OUT THE
SATELLITE IMAGES WE HAVE NOW.
ON THE LEFT JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR, ON THE RIGHT NOVEMBER.
YOU CAN SEE THE LIGHTS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THIS UNDERSCORES THE CHALLENGE
THAT UKRAINE NOW FACES BUT OF
COURSE THOSE SCENES FROM THOSE
MEDICAL FACILITIES SHOW THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO KEEP
TRYING TO RESTORE ELECTRICITY,
EVEN AS THE RISK REMAINS IT'S
GOING TO GET KNOCKED BACK OUT
AGAIN.
>> CAN WE PUT THOSE IMAGES UP.
YOU CAN SEE FROM SPACE HOW BAD
THE BLACKOUTS AND HOW SEVERE
THEY ARE.
THIS IS REMARKABLE TO SEE THE
SIDE BY SIDE IMAGES OF THAT OF
WHAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE DEALING
WITH, EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE
DEALING WITH, AND THE FACT THAT
WINTER IS SETTING IN AND THEY'RE
DEALING WITH THIS.
IT'S REMARKABLE.
>> IT'S RAMPING UP AS WELL.
THE ATTACKS STARTED ON
SUBSTATIONS THROUGHOUT THE GRID.
NOW THEY'RE ATTACKING THE
GENERATION CAPACITY ITSELF WITH
THE NUCLEAR PLANTS, HYDRO
ELECTRIC PLANTS AND ALL AS
WINTER STARTS TO SET IN.
PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH IT ON A
DAY-TO-DAY BASIS, CONSERVE
ENERGY, SAVE WATER AND FOR
REGULAR PEOPLE THEY KEEP DOING
IT EVEN WHEN THE WATER COMES
BACK BECAUSE THEY FEEL IT CAN
DISAPPEAR AT ANY MOMENT.
>> THANK YOU.
SO, THANKS --
INTERVENE FOR.
STRUCTURE LET'S --
HEATING IN THE WINTER IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND CAN BE LIFE-THREATENING, AS
WE SAW THOSE DOCTORS OPERATING
WITH HEADLINES, THEY'RE UTTERLY
ATTACKS ON THE WATER SYSTEM
THAT THEY FEAR MOST.
RUSSIA HAS MIXED RESULTS AT
BEST ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
BUT THESE TACTICS OF GOING AND
VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BEEN
INCREASINGLY SUCCESSFUL, IT
SEEMS.
>> IT CERTAINLY HAS.
I THINK RUSSIA'S GOAL HERE IS
TO INFLICT AS MUCH MISERY AND
PAIN AND THE CREAM PEOPLE IN
TERMS OF TACKLING THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ELECTRICITY,
WATER, TELECOMMUNICATIONS, TO
BASICALLY --
BREAK THEIR WILL.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOT TO WORK
BECAUSE UKRAINIANS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE OPTION OF
SURRENDER IF THEY BASICALLY GO
INTO A NEGOTIATION AS A RESULT
OF THESE ATTACKS AND THEN HAND
OVER TERRITORY IN THE AREAS
SUCH AS THE DONBAS AND THAT WE
TEAR AND CARSON.
THEN THEY ARE ABANDONING PEOPLE
TO THE REALITY OF THE RUSSIANS,
WHICH WE HAVE SEEN IN BUCHA.
THE CRANES ARE FIGHTING FOR
THEIR SURVIVAL.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO GIVE UP
SO.
THEY WILL STRUGGLE TO THIS
WINTER AND COME OUT THE OTHER
SIDE AND BE READY TO CONTINUE
TO FIGHT.
>> OKAY.
SO IF RUSSIA'S GOAL IS TO
WEAKEN CRANIUM RESOLVED ENSUED
WORKING, WHAT ABOUT RUSSIA'S
ANTI BLACK AGAINST YOUR?
WILL THAT RESULT IN MORE
PRESSURE BEING BROUGHT TO BEAR
ON UKRAINE TO NEGOTIATE?
>> I THINK THAT'S A GREATER
CONCERN.
ESSENTIALLY, THE RUSSIANS ARE
SENSING THAT THERE ARE
VULNERABILITIES, FRACTURES AND
FISSURES IN EUROPE, IN TERMS OF
SUSTAINING SUPPORT FOR THE
UKRAINIANS IN TERMS OF MILITARY
ASSISTANCE.
THE UKRAINIANS --
I THINK THE RUSSIANS ARE ALSO
BEING THERE WILL BE A
FRACTURING OF SUPPORT IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH THE, GO I,
THINK OF TRYING TO CONVINCE
EUROPE AND THE UNITED STATES TO
ESSENTIALLY TALK TO UKRAINIANS
INTO AN EARLY NEGOTIATION AND A
CEASE-FIRE THAT WOULD GIVE THE
RUSSIANS THEM TIME TO REBUILD
AND REGROUP THEIR FORCES AND
ALSO, POTENTIALLY, TO IN ERODE
COMPETENCE, ESSENTIALLY, IN
UKRAINE'S ABILITY TO CONTINUE
THE FIGHT, PARTICULARLY IF THIS
RESULT OF THAT PRESSURE THE
SUPPLY OF MILITARY CAPABILITY
TO SEEK RAINDROPS OFF.
SO I THINK THERE HAS TO BE
IPHONE PUSH BACK AGAINST THE
RUSSIAN EFFORT TO BLACKBALL
EUROPE AND TO COURSE EUROPE
INTO ENDING SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE.
>> YEAH AND WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
SOME WEAKENING OF SUPPORT AT
LEAST HERE IN THE U.S. FROM
CERTAIN SEGMENTS OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SO LOOKING AHEAD THEN AT THE
BATTLEFIELD SITUATION FOR,
OFTEN WE HEAR THINGS WILL COME
TO A HALT DURING THE HARSH
WINTER.
BUT YOU DON'T SEEM TO THINK SO.
WENT UP?
>> I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HISTORY OF WARFARE THERE ARE
MANY EXAMPLES OF BATTLES THAT
CONTINUE RIGHT THROUGH THE
HARSHEST WINTERS.
ONE EXAMPLE IS THE BATTLE OF
THE BELGIAN 1944.
SO I THINK THAT YOU WILL SEE
THE WAR CONTINUE THROUGHOUT
THIS WAR --
WINTER THAT UKRAINE SAID THEY
CAN'T LET UP THE PRESSURE ON
THE RUSSIANS.
THE RUSSIANS WILL CONTINUE TO
REINFORCE THEIR DEFENSIVE
POSITIONS IN KHERSON AND IN THE
DONBAS.
AND BOTH SIDES WILL BE
PREPARING THEMSELVES FOR A
RETURN TO A FULL INTENSITY
OPERATIONS IN THE NORTHERN
SPRING IN THE SUMMER SIDE.
IT MAY SLOW DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
BUT IT DON'T SEE IT NECESSARILY
COMING TO A GRINDING HALT.
>> ALL RIGHT, BEFORE WE GO, TO
KEEP WAGING THAT WAR, RUSSIA IS
RUNNING OUT OF MILITARY
HARDWARE BUT GETTING BY LOOKING
FROM IRAN, NOT JUST THE DRONES
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT IMPACT DO YOU THINK THAT
WILL HAVE ON RUSSIA'S ABILITY
TO KEEP TRY TO WEAR UKRAINE
DOWN?
>> I THINK IT COULD BE DECISIVE
IF THE IRANIANS PROVIDE THE
RUSSIANS WITH MORE?
ADVANCED STRIKE CAPABILITIES IN
THE FORM OF SURFACE TO SURFACE
BALLISTIC MISSILES, SUCH AS THE
--
FATTER WON TEN AND THE DOCK
ABOUT, WHICH HAVE MUCH GREATER
PRECISION AND A MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE UKRAINIANS TO
ACCEPT JUST BECAUSE OF THE
SHEER SPEED OF THE MISSILE,
THEN THE RUSSIANS CAN SUDDENLY
OPEN UP AND WIDEN THEIR
CAMPAIGN AGAINST UKRAINIAN
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL
AS UKRAINIAN MILITARY
INFRASTRUCTURE, AIR BASES PORTS,
AND COMMANDING CONTROL CENTERS
AND THAT SORT OF THING.
AND --
THE PROVISION OF THOSE IRANIAN
MISSILES AS OPPOSED TO THE
DRONES, I THINK, COULD BE QUITE
SIGNIFICANT.
SO, WHAT YOU WOULD THEN SEE IS
UKRAINE QUITE RIGHTLY ASKING
FOR GREAT GREATER PROTECTION
FROM THOSE IRANIAN MISSILES.
AND THAT COULD INVOLVE THE
PROVISION OF MORE ADVANCED
BALLISTIC MISSILE EVENTS
CAPABILITIES FROM THE WEST.
>> IT'S ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
HEAR YOUR ANALYSIS, MALCOLM
DAVIS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING.